hi my name is wner
hog and I feel a little bit weird about
being Conan O'Brien's friend because I
met him only once and that was in front
of cameras yes yes and so verer you
don't know who I really am you saw Conan
the performer and uh so you don't really
know if you could be my friend you don't
know what kind of course and we have
seen each other only once cameras
rolling and we haven't hit the bars we
haven't been in high school together we
haven't rafted down a jungle River and
so
on yes yes yes I understand that it's
going to be harder for me to become your
close friend than it is it won't Happ in
uh in half an hour or an hour of being
together but that's fine let's let's
let's try our best any what
about if it were to exist would you say
5 hours would do it or are you talking
it would take maybe uh more than more
lifetime than either of us has left it
actually has happened in my life once or
twice that I became an instantaneous
friend to somebody W I played uh in a
soccer team which was the best in Peru
at the time yes and I just did the um
condition training with them but all of
a sudden when they had a the team a
playing playing against Team B there was
one player missing and the coach said
you play Team B which position would you
like to play and I said I want to play
against one of the best in the world was
in that team he was voted as one of the
11 best players in the world after the
World Championships gardo a speed freak
and I tried to give him problems and be
an obstacle and after 10 minutes I
didn't know which uh which direction we
were playing yes I I didn't know which
uh Jersey we were completely confounded
you he confounded me Bamboozled me and I
was so exhausted after 10 minutes that I
crawled off the field and vomited in in
some bushes for an hour and a half
please of one guy pulls me out on my
legs and talks to me and he says you did
well you played against one of the best
in the world doesn't matter if you're
defeated like that and we were friends
instantly oh so it wasn't the soccer
player that you became friends you
became friends with the man who pulled
you out of the bushes while vomiting yes
exactly so that's a guy who you could
instantaneously be friends with but
Conan O'Brien no not
possible I hope that you start to vomit
at some point in this interview and I
will rescue you I will not well we'll
see drink this I have a little something
in there um well I'm going to say
something else uh what do I call you
because I have great respect for you do
I call just call me Verner okay first
name is it Verner with a V well we say
Verner in in German don't
try I'm going to try
V yeah well no it it will be too too
rough tough okay I won't do it let War
uh let me say that I know from reading
your book which by the way let me just
give the title of this book every man
for himself and God against all thank
God this isn't a children's book yeah
can you imagine
saying okay little Timmy it's time to go
to sleep we're going to read every man
from self and God against all sure yes I
don't think that boy would ever go to
sleep that's a terrifying idea um but I
read your book and you describe yourself
as a bit of a loner do you have a big
circle of friends or it's not your
natural way no uh circle of real friends
is small mhm and very intense yes the
only problem is that I live so far out
and that's Los Angeles and my friends
are in Peru they are in Germany they are
in India yes they are in uh Sicily MH so
it's that's is the hard part of it
here's a question that just occurred to
me we now have this technology that
really uh exploded and and zoom and
everyone is saying well it's fantastic
because I can keep up my friendships
with people who live far away I a
problem with zoom I don't feel like I'm
really communicating with the person
when I'm on Zoom it doesn't feel I feel
like something essential as being
extracted yeah from the interaction is
that possible you're totally right
although I use it but uh I use it only
with people whom I know very well MH so
uh but I have to refresh the physical
contact with them I want to embrace them
directly once in a while I want to laugh
with them I want to cook a meal for them
yes so and and then it's okay that you
do one or two Zoom calls sometimes there
business Zoom calls they have to be made
because there is somebody involved in a
project who is in Australia somebody who
is in the United Kingdom in London and
I'm in Los Angeles so it's very hard to
get them together I'm trying to imagine
when you would create uh and I was
thinking about your whole body of work
which is mindboggling there are so many
times where you've put yourself in
extreme positions as a director and I'm
thinking that that you couldn't just sit
still in your office and be on a zoom
you would need to be on a raft floating
down a river in Peru battling the
elements on your zoom while everyone
else was talking do you know what I mean
that you would you verer hsog would have
to be does it it feels like that would
be the kind of Zoom you would want to
have is to put yourself way out there no
you have to be really out there and zoom
is belong somewhere else it's a it's a
different world and you you have to make
a decision do you want to use it for
what purposes for example I'm probably
the last hold out who doesn't use a cell
phone you don't have a cell phone I
don't have a cell phone now but um it's
for cultural Reasons I'm not nostalgic
so I I I want to derive my interaction
or my knowledge of of the real world
in in direct contact with the world the
most intense would be traveling on foot
which I have done this is a quote you
said it in your book and it really stuck
with me uh the world reveals itself to
those who travel on foot yeah it's
important to you to walk and see things
in real time it's not just real time you
are
unprotected when you travel on foot and
I don't meet backpacking with your own
whole household on your back uh your
tent your sleeping bag your cooking
utensil and so on um and I'm a lazy bum
like everyone else I would not uh travel
on foot unless there was an
existentially important reason for it
mhm for example I would travel on foot
when my mentor very old woman by then 80
years old uh um Jewish who had fled Nazi
Germany from the day when Hitler took
power and she was in hiding in France
during the second world war and the Nazi
regime and she became my mentor and was
very important and when she was dying I
said I'm not flying I'm not taking the
train or I'm not going by car I will
come on foot a thousand kilometers oh
wow and it was early winter in
snowstorms in hail and rain and whatever
and I would sleep on the bridges
sometimes sometimes in the hay uh of a
barn or I would open um vacation home
that was uninhabited with uh some sort
of tools surgical tools without breaking
a lock I can open it and close it again
and sleep in there so and and she was
out of hospital by the way when I
arrived and she uh incredible 8 years
later when she was 88 probably 88
because we do not know exactly how old
she
became um she celebrated her 75th
birthday at least twice maybe three
times normally women start to cheat
about their age much earlier but she had
75 I've been celebrating my 35th now for
a long time she summoned me eight years
later she summons me to Paris and she
said to me uh just over a cup of tea uh
uh you know uh there's still this spell
upon me that I must not die you put that
spell on me and I'm old now I'm almost
blind I cannot read books which is the
joy of my life I cannot see movies which
is the other Joy of my life I'm lame I
can barely walk so can you lift the
spell off off of me and I said okay yes
it's lifted and eight days later she
died and it was good it was right uh she
um had put me in a position where I had
become
independent and strong and
self-confident and and you just name it
well you know this you you touch on this
that's a beautiful story you touch on
your uh your childhood which is not of
this I mean clearly not of this Century
but it feels like your your childhood
could have been 400 years ago you grew
up in such poverty uh you grow up in
this I mean you're born as you say in
the book at this moment when fortunes
are changing for the German Army in
North Africa uh uh raml is about to
start losing and uh the Germans have
invaded Stalingrad which is the
beginning of the end so but you grow up
in this great tumult yeah and terrible
poverty and you say that you weren't
really aware that you were poor other
than you were hungry a lot uh yes that's
when you really know you're poor and my
mother would have a loaf of bread one
loaf for my two brothers and me and her
four people and she would make a Groove
for each day and each of us had one thin
slice of bread per day but normally by
Friday when we were so hungry we had
eaten the whole loaf of of bread and we
hoped that she would find something
somewhere but sometimes it it was always
uh Saturday Sunday that was the worst uh
when there was nothing so and uh I
remember that very well and uh we were
wailing and tugging at her skirt and she
spun I remember her very well for that
she spins
around
completely completely
composed but with an anger and despair
in her face that I've never seen before
after and very calmly she says
boys if I could cut it out of my ribs I
would cut it out of my ribs but I can't
so you shut up and that made a big big
impression on me of course but uh many
people have grown up hungry or or or
poor there's nothing wrong about that
for for children it's it's much easier
than for for the parents when a mother
cannot Feed the Children anymore that's
a real awful
thing